[Music]
hi I'm ready Maya Google developer
advocate I'm joined here today by Dave
ransom director of customer reliability
engineering now Dave Fieri's renowned
for being able to take care of or at
least expect pretty much any contingency
you know but there are certain laws of
nature that you can take for granted
right lightning never strikes twice as
far as lightning never strikes twice
that was clearly invented by someone who
has never worked in a data center in
Belgium we had one that actually got hit
by lightning four times within a few
minutes so avoid taking shelter in data
centers in Belgium yeah yeah or maybe
God just doesn't like cloud data centers
in Belgium think we'll move on to me
tell me Dave where can people find more
stories like this well if you're going
to be at Google next you should stop by
the fifth nine lounge dedicated space
where you can meet Google senior sre
series customer DevOps people and learn
about all the wacky wild and well
downright weird stuff we have to deal
with day today we look forward to seeing
you there